Be fearless.
Change is good.
I don't really care
if I sleep too much.
It's kind of fun,
to see how much
one can do in a day.
I want to look pretty,
but not too made up.
Not that I ever
look very made up.
I was able to turn
I started my company
when I was 50 years old.
My work is based
on need and want.
It’s extremely powerful
to take an
idea, and turn it
into a
billion-dollar business.
This is what I
want to look like.
That is my look.
Hard work
is essential
to making an
idea come to life,
and I love
hard workers.
Ah, that is
such a cake.
If you can
find somebody
that's going
to be as good
or better
than you,
embrace them,
and bring them in.
That's the one I took.
How much THC
was in that
one I got?
1 milligram.
Don’t want to
put you to sleep.
I try to
look forward.
When you’re through
changing, you’re through.
I’m Martha Stewart,
and this is MasterClass.